be like tyler get buckets
more gentrification in brooklyn steve
nash named the head coach of the net
every single year lebron is the best
player in the playoffs td will not be
back at full strength
[Music]
twitter update stat uh everyone's
talking about the conference finals
who's the best player in the league you
mean second best right
no no but sir you're coming off and kill
me
look i need you to facilitate
growth so tweet at them
this season doesn't even count anyway
laugh now cry later
what about ig uh someone said you should
stop playing
grab ass with drake and start playing in
real games
but but i wouldn't worry about him look
he's about games with two g's
hack into his account and like every
single
one of his ex's posts from two years ago
ha ha ha yes yes sir
now what about tv yes sir yes sir
uh a reporter said that he thinks that
even with a new coach your personality
will be and i quote
the iceberg that will sink the nets
bring me the list
pack them in a confined space no a
shooting percentage discussion
no uh uh cairo explains gravity no
jerusalem no the borderland
yes the boardroom we will make him watch
the boardroom
the extended director's cut send files
immediately yes
yes man
i would never mess with kd
that dude is fish fish vicious
fish vicious
yeah glenn on the set
quad on the set all right tyler once
again let's take it
from the top i want to do a good job but
i'm not an actor
tyler it's not acting if you believe it
and action i'm tyler i'm a bucket
who gets buckets
was that was that good
was brilliant ah
ah cut print check the gate
moving on be like tyler
give buckets how have i not gotten to
tony
how